representantes de la comisión europea
liderada por su presidenta Úrsula
founder Legends se han reunido con el
presidente del gobierno Pedro Sánchez y
también con los representantes del
gobierno español con motivo del inicio
de la presidencia rotatoria del Consejo
de la Unión Europea que ostenta España
durante seis meses hasta diciembre ambos
mandatarios tanto bonderlayen como Pedro
Sánchez han abordado las prioridades de
la presidencia española muy marcada
sobre todo por la guerra en Ucrania en
que Pedro Sánchez ha asegurado que hay
que apostar Ahora más que nunca por el
apoyo a Ucrania y también por abrir las
negociaciones de adhesión antes de
finalizar el año tal y como pide el
presidente ucraniano
también la presente la comisión europea
Úrsula founder Legend asegura que España
toma la presidencia del Consejo en un
momento clave del conflicto en que hay
que redoblar la ayuda financiera y
militar a Ucrania además Pedro ha hecho
hincapié en que hay que reducir las
dependencias externas y apostar por la
competitividad europea especialmente
confiando en socios más fiables y ha
puesto como ejemplo en los países de
América Latina con motivo de la Cumbre
de la celac la esperada reunión que
tendrá lugar entre aquí a dos semanas A
mediados de Julio en Bruselas los
líderes han asegurado que esta Cumbre
puede marcar un antes y un después entre
ambos bloques la presidencia española es
muy esperada porque tiene importantes
retos importantes carteras y dossieres
por cerrar Como por ejemplo el pacto
migratorio aunque se produce en un
momento de máxima tensión aquí en España
con unas elecciones de aquí apenas 21
días